each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
it's his CEO actually filled with us a
few years ago so that's how small it
will live but you know it's a pleasure
to have shown here he's going to tell us
today about some work unit dynasty with
the device of the Wilson theory on
designing a little language okay so this
talk is going to be about language
design not not program analysis so just
just to to be clear on that actually the
language is not a language to implement
components but to blue blue components
together so here's here's here's the
idea here's the objectives and the
language is called superglue and what
we're trying to do is we're trying to
simplify the development of interactive
programs or programs with components
that generally you know interact with
each other as opposed to running in
pipelines and we're going to focus on
the glue code for these programs and
this what this what this does is it we
really do emphasize the algorithmic
complexity of the code we focus more on
on integration issues and we don't worry
about how the components are implemented
we just assume they can be implemented
in a standard conventional programming
language okay so basically interactive
programs are most commonly used to build
sort of user interfaces and the sort of
architecture that that's done under is
that you might have some data to be
viewed like a like a mailbox or an email
system and you might have a user
interface to view that data and the idea
is that the the data source is modeling
the data whereas the the data processor
is viewing the data and this is sort of
a part of the Model View controller
design pattern and to get these get
these components working together so we
have components that provide models I
mean components that provide views
to get them to work together we have to
write out some glue code to to get these
components to call each other's
functions and generally this this glue
code is implementing sort of two kinds
of behaviors in these applications one
is for the view can request the current
data from the model whenever it wants to
so it sort of says okay what value are
you now and the other kind of
communication that goes on here that the
glue code establishes is sort of event
driven notification communication so
it's basically it's when the when does
your value change so the model will say
my value change now you have to update
your reasoning about my data court of
with respect to that change ok so these
changes also here are and the request
the request current from the user
interface user interface to the glue
code and the notify change from the
models to the glue code they're in the
wrong direction because the glue code is
setting everything up so you can't have
your components calling the glue code so
what you do instead is you install
various callbacks to get these
components to communicate with each
other and so these these clawbacks are
sort of difficult to write and they're
not just the callbacks but just getting
the components to communicate or
difficult is difficult because the
component interfaces don't match each
other right so we generally have we
generally have objects with a bunch of
methods and you know different different
objects have different methods and they
don't use compatible api's basically so
what happens is that your glue code has
to go ahead and adapt each object to
each other's interface and this is
especially problematic at the level of
event handling so we have these methods
down here says you know for a user
interface table we have the table
changed method that's that notifies the
table that its view data has changed and
for the for an email folder we have
message added and messaged removed
functions that
I are called when data changes you know
you register call back it calls and you
implement these callbacks to to call the
the table and this code is sort of
difficult not it's basically you have to
do a lot of work getting these these
api's to work together and that's one
problem with glue code and that's the
problem trying to solve in this language
and the other problem oops is um
composability so this is a little bit
more trickier is basically is that you
have a lot of different components and
they're providing a lot of state they're
each providing their own state and you
want to get this state to work together
do you want to compose a state into sort
of compound states better then that are
then used there then viewed by another
component so what we have here is sort
of a composability problem which is to
take the folder that's selected in the
UI tree view and say if that we want to
view the folders of this messages in a
UI tape I you uitableview and to do that
we have to write a lot of more glue code
and I'm not going to show you the glue
code I just have a flow diagram of what
it looks like so you start off by
installing a tree selection listener on
your your user interface tree and you go
and implement a callback that that when
it's called you're going to uninstall
and install a message countless in
tirana email folder and you're going to
plement another callback that takes
messages when they're added and removed
and you're going to update the table
court accordingly so writing this code
let's say maybe 30 40 lines of Java code
to implement this behavior so the
solution i'm going to propose here and
actually follow through with a language
is we're going to use sort of these
abstractions known as signals to sort of
facilitate communication between
components right so a signal is sort of
like a as we call them time varying
values but basically they have a value
and every time you look at it it's going
to change so they very continuous
with time but more practically speaking
a signal is just an abstraction that
encapsulates behavior related to the
communication of state so it's going to
have within within the signal
abstraction we're going to have
facilities for getting the current value
and for installing and uninstalling
event handlers that are called when the
value changes right and so once we've
had this abstraction so it's basically
an API you can think of it but the idea
is that the language runtime understands
this API and is able to to use that in
the construction of what we call
circuits that can then compose these
abstractions so the first thing is we
have the signals you write your
components to the signals and your
components become compatible the second
thing is that we have circuits that
allow you to compose signals together
which allow you to compose state ok and
so this is basically an architecture of
the language so we have components we're
going to just implement them in the
prototype is using Java we use and
implement signals in Java code we call
them drivers that translate between
super super glue code and and Java code
and then outside the blue code is
basically expressing a bunch of circuits
that facilitate communication between
these components ok so that's yes
basically it's for building circuits the
components can be implemented in Java or
they can be implemented in super glue
and then you have to translate between
the two language is sort of like a
native method interface that you would
have in other languages so it's ok I'd
spend by the component implementer so I
mean if you want if you want the
component to work you have to in the in
the language you have to write these
drivers that make the components api's
available that's a bit trickier then I
but it
so the idea is that you are implementing
a link your rippling component that will
be reused many times so if you're doing
a user interface library it's reasonable
to expect that you know you'd have you
know thousands of programs depending on
your user interface library so the
driver the drivers class is Emmett
Erised over all those those on those
uses of the library now if you have a
one-off application you have legacy code
that you want to reuse then you have to
write this complicated driver that might
not make it worthwhile you can also
write some simple comparison in super
glue so it's not it's only these
complicated components that need to be
written in this language so there's a
problem with this connection model it's
not very scalable so it works great when
we're connecting making connection
between two components one connection
between two components we just say okay
connect these components together but
you know applications have a large
number of connections and possibly an
unbounded number of connections when you
get into data structures like lists and
trees so sort of the unique contribution
in our language is that we are applying
object-oriented abstractions where we're
combining up signal abstractions with
object abstractions to get object
oriented signals and basically we have a
way of expressing expressing in circuits
how you express connections by type
between two objects as opposed to
expressing connections individually so
the idea is when you when you're
expressing so think about to your won't
me just go back here sort of abstract
but we get when we hear when you're
expressing how your individual circuits
are so if you're going back to your I
mean I know if you have digital design
logic class before but you you sort of
you plop down chips and you express how
those chips are connected right and
that's that you if you have a lot of if
you have a few pins that's okay but if
you have a thousand pins or 10,000 pins
that's not not okay you need some higher
level of abstraction
to sort of manage those connections
connections are totally and so
components signals out other the
promoted benefit of that the volume has
always been that it feels really well
you not be here how many components are
looking for a signal or or how many
transformations are going on yeah for
some systems that actually works pretty
well for a lot of systems though you
don't that's not that's not the right
abstraction so this is this is you can
think you can think of this is another
another architecture if you want to
think it in terms of a software
architecture this is just another this
is the model-view-controller
architecture link put into a language as
opposed to a blackboard architecture so
blackboard architecture works for for
some programs it i mean it's it's got
you know it you don't see if you don't
see it a lot out of outside of
artificial intelligence and agent stuff
but you know it's not used a lot in user
interfaces for example but it's another
way of attacking this is basically with
a well-known architecture and this is
just another example of a well-known
architecture that can be that can be
used sort of a really large domain so so
i'm feeling that well this is so if you
so I basic so as I said before that this
is sort of model view controller
architecture so that niche that's that
then it has already been established I
think and if you look at a lot of the
object oriented programming API is they
use on model view controller a lot I'm
not quite sure about specific Microsoft
api's but you know Apple Java API is are
all heavily biased to model view
controller so there's you know
there's that niche is basically a lot of
there's a lot of code out there that
already sort of follows this
architecture sure and I should point out
that this is not you know signals are
not my invention I mean this is this is
actually there's a Microsoft Research
Eva de canela Elliott is a is a language
guy and he wrote he did a into the paper
on event sort of Advent driven
programming in Haskell so I mean signals
have been around in Haskell for a while
and they're making their way into
functional programming languages now on
the the difference between their work
and my work would be deaf basically the
way it's being presented here I'm
presenting it in a and sort of a
language that's designed for ease of use
and you know the Haskell people are more
interested in formalisms and some other
you know other people of different sort
of different different needs but this
basically this is a combination of
object-oriented and signal techniques so
so basically we're going to be able to
abstract / connections like you can
abstract / method implementations in a
knob in an object I know programming and
I won't explain this I won't explain
these this illustration right now I'll
get back to it later but it's basically
the idea is clean up the connection so
you have you can express a few
connections and abstractly and get a lot
of connections out and your run and
you're executing program so that's sort
of the end of my introduction the rest
of this talk I will just go through the
language start out with signals just
basically explain what those are at a
basic level and then go into objects
which is my sort of my mic or
contribution and then I'll kind of talk
about how effective this language is if
you had an evaluation and then I'll get
to my conclusion so signals so this is
sort of a simple program in super glue
what's going on here is that we're
declaring two objects we're declaring a
thermometer object in the label object
which which is a sort of a user
interface widget and we'll call those
model object than the view object and
we're basically attaching the current
temperature to as viewed through the
thermometer to the view to the label
that should be text not labeled I don't
know why and what happens is that
whenever that that value changes right
the the labels going to change
automatically now that's that's what
signals do okay so that is a connection
so you're connecting two pins together
so I mean you can think of it as a
constraint but I would I would you know
there's there's there's there's
advantages and disadvantages yeah I mean
yeah so yes it's basically a direction
so you're saying something something
that requires something is is being
connected to something that provides
something it's not necessarily like a
constraint where you can take arbitrary
variables of you know and say that
they're equal or greater than or
something like that it wouldn't work
like that you would have to have an
input and an output to connect its you
know that you can think of it as a
function or you can think of it as a
rule I like to think of them as rules
and this is basically establishing
something that can be used to prove what
label is assigned to or what value label
has at any point in the program hi yeah
these two yeah this is the nice thing
about assignment here is that is a well
established precedent
so I mean this there's there's
advantages to using a different symbol I
mean I've conquered these arguments with
my advisor a lot let's put that way I
you know there's advantages to using
different symbols and this this which
sort of make it easier for people you
know in Java this website well I can
kind of think of this code like Java
code except it's continuous evaluation
instead of you know sort of sequential
ordered evaluation but you know I mean a
different different symbol might make it
look like Haskell and nobody would go
near the language so there's there's a
lot of things to consider you can you
can do that you can you can you can
connect things in cycles and the program
will will blow up I mean you can connect
you can connect components now there's
no fixed point this is basically you
know you would bisque you would create a
feedback loop and you a dumb you would
you an infinite loop there's a type
system not yet well this not functions
that the idea is that you know they have
to basically some things providing data
and something's consuming data and
that's that's the constraint now inside
the implementations of the components
they can do whatever they want with the
data right but the idea is that they
have this very simple API to work that
they have to work through the signal API
so and there's no there's no there's no
there's no constraint system that
prevents feedbacks from coming in I mean
it's something we can add later but you
know right now we're trying to get the
sort of the usefulness of the language
established before you know looking at
the other details like you know not
shooting yourself in the foot so
no definitely not so that would be the
other work the Haskell work they have a
synchronous model of signals so
basically what they do is they evaluate
for each each individual time T and they
get sort of the safe concurrency type
behavior which is incredibly inefficient
but it's you know it's very very well
behaved this this work is asynchronous
so you're up and you're on your own for
concurrency auy programs they can run in
one loop so it's not not such a big big
deal you're using event handling instead
of multiple threads you know if you had
multiple threads going around you would
have to start you would have to start
adding connections to start communicate
about about concurrency right so we'd be
one of the drawbacks of my system as
opposed to the high school people which
have decided that they're going to make
time explicit and deal with the issues
accordingly okay so we move on a little
bit here the nice thing about the system
is that we can have so I'm sticking to I
try to stick to comment syntax here I'm
trying to use I'm trying to reuse
existing syntax whenever possible even
though I'm changing sort of what they
mean in the sense that it's going to be
continuous evaluation as opposed to
sequential evaluation but here we have
an if statement if else statement that
connects the color of the label and what
this is is you can read this as a
continuous function that connects the
color of of label two different two
different colors based on what the
current temperature is so like if the
temperature is greater than 90 it can be
read less than 40 it can be blue and
then you know otherwise black but the
idea is that we can think of you know if
you're coming from a from C++ Java and C
sharp line you can think of this as well
true you know you're just running you're
just running your code in an infinite
loop and each time each time you go
through the loop you can you can update
the color a problem however there are no
loops here we just you just write it
like that and you sassoon that
everything you just to assume that these
connections are always being constantly
updated and the way that's implemented
is through sort of the event handling
interface that the signals that the
signals provide
ok so I just want to just want to
demonstrate this really quickly really
really simple demo here why Shh very
good
so here we have our label and then here
i have the thermometer which i'm going
to control you know it's just modeling
as a slider we you know up above 90 it's
it's red and a below below 40 it's blue
now what i can do is i can change this
program just a little bit so here's the
code it's a little bit different from
when i showed you the slides but not you
know quite i can take the text that i
can change it to do celsius instead of
fahrenheit and that works now notice
that the temperature is being measured
in fahrenheit so if i move the slider up
you know we're getting the we're getting
the 90 in fahrenheit but it's being
translated to celsius that's all very
very simple program to sort of to sort
of describe what you can do with signals
and sort of the simple sense
yeah I could have I could have added a I
could have added what we'll get into
switching later but I mom this is I
could have added another like check box
widget for example that and I could
actually do it right now oh I don't want
to set it up but so I actually made this
example really simple sound it's not
easy to change but you can add a
textbook a check box widget right and
when it's clicked you have it in Celsius
and when it's not clicked you have it in
Fahrenheit and what happens at runtime
you know as soon as you unclick so as
soon as you click the check box you know
it starts translating it so the other
the other the other branch of the if
statement becomes active
yeah you mean you could you could add a
way you could you could you could add a
way of interposing the behavior so this
is just for this example it's just
easier to to retype temperature twice
you could add something that would
translate the signal if another signal
was true or not and but quite simply you
know that's often just if so I mean
maybe people often want to just write
that as if there's no there's no reason
to have an extra component there
sometimes that's not true sometimes you
want to sometimes you need to actually
start talking about components that do
their own switching but most the time if
it should be good enough sure um we
could so well here I have more than one
definition for color right so color is
they're guarded right you'd have to
guard your definition you'd have to
prioritize your connections right you
can't have you can't you can't have your
your connections on prioritize and you
have two different sliders yeah if I put
that look general when I wrote the
second one is always yeah so I think it
was a data flow model and signified
change
yeah yeah so this is this is where this
is where the data flow model will start
speaking its head up so yeah you can
think of you can think of this as
sequential code as long as you as long
as you limit yourself to assigning
variables only once in a path um that's
the way I'm going to describe it next
yeah you know there's there's two
different thoughts you know you want you
want these languages to be accessible to
program means is this language does this
language is designed to be easy so you
want to be accessible to two programmers
that might think of the code differently
you know you want to trick them into
using a declarative language basically
now you know obviously it's a
declarative language in any you know we
all know that right but mmm yeah I could
switch the ordering as long but for the
ELSA fright you know the f
prioritization has to be sure yeah now
there are features in the language that
are very imperative that well that we're
ordering does matter but I'll get to
those later signals signal is state
signal is state so time varying values
right they're basically just they're
just basically representing state
volatile state that changes ya know
yeah you need you need to use different
you need to use additional components to
do that and you would have to use event
handling which is a different different
interface from the signal connection so
there are there are facilities in the
language that let you do that but you
have to that you have to get away from
the nice sort of signal connection model
because now you're actually now you're
actually concerned now you're actually
interested in the control flow of the
program as soon as you're not interested
in the control as long as you're not
interested in the control flow of how
these these things communicate you don't
have to do a lot of work but as soon as
you want to know sure yeah so this so
since this is asynchronous right we're
kind of assuming a sort of instantaneous
model that there's no delay propagation
delay or anything like that now that's
not true obviously there's going to be
time difference between when an event is
delivered and received but we don't we
don't make any guarantees about that so
if you want if you want to depend on any
kind of sort of timing timing in the
circuit you're not gonna be able to that
in the system
um okay I'm not really familiar with I
I'm not really familiar with the
spreadsheets but it's yeah i mean that's
possibly true but let me get me as i
explained the language it become more
clear so let's go back to the slides so
getting back to how you think about this
code so the while loop is not the best
you know it's not the way that this code
works it all these all these all these
um if statements are all compiled into a
circuit and here we show the circuit for
connecting the color signal and just to
go through a little bit of the terminal
terminology but the graphics hear that
little inverter gate up there or the
triangle that's a condition so if it's
if the line coming in is true then it
passes through the output coming coming
in from both the left and then the
multiplexer of the switch there is um
that's you know it's a prioritize switch
so it takes the highest active output
and passes it through to the to the
color and then the triangle of the
diamonds down there are simple greater
than or less than conditions okay so
let's go through a little bit so this is
this is how this is how that code I just
showed you is actually represented in
the system no no no I mean it is a
representation of of the rule system
that's going on there's actual data
structure called circuit but it's just a
it's just a list of conditions that have
to be true to pass through the output um
this is just a graphical representation
of that so so we can have our
temperature when it's greater than 90 um
this you know coming up from the from
the greater than symbol is going to be a
live sort of signal that's true and
that's going to allow us to pass through
red to the color now as soon as that's
not true anymore as soon as as soon as
the temperature is not greater than 90
stop passing through that the the red
color to the through the switch okay so
the same thing happens when bluest when
for when the temperature is less than 40
we pass through blue and likewise if if
the temperature is not less than 40 it's
not greater than 90 then we're going to
just pass through black that's our
default connection so the switches
completely prioritize and as soon as
it's greater than 90 again we'd be
passed through red that's how the switch
works this continues behavior now if you
think of the syntax that I showed you
there's there's really you know this
these it's not really else here because
you know else has the semantics is
purely control flow else is a nice way
of saying as specifying prioritize good
connections but you know you can't you
can't say if something you know view dot
color equals blue otherwise view text
equals hello I mean because you're
connecting two different two different
two different signals there you know we
have we can only prioritize within one
signal within one connection signal or
the same things yes it's sort of well
what happens is that if you if you
connect things that are unrelated to
each other I'll let you do that and
actually you might want to express
multiple connections within their
qualified by 11 if statement and then
you're in another else statement you
might specify other connections but but
what will happen is that they won't have
the else like behavior that you would
expect you to bake a lot of this date
sure and then the idea is the idea is to
have a checker or type check a type
checking system there's there's there's
a trade-off here between sort of
preventing the programmers from writing
programs easily and you know with an
easy type system and if the type system
is too restrictive you know they can't
do a lot of things that they
want to do so there's there's that kind
of balance there at the stage where
somebody knows what they doing you'll be
with them too quickly connecting may not
necessarily know what they're doing yes
but we're going for the latter people
eventually so I mean the else the else
issue right where you connect different
signals of you connect different signals
in else clauses we would want to come up
with a sort of a nice solution that says
hey you're you're connecting these
things and they don't they don't really
you know this this disconnection there's
a connection made in this else statement
that it's not correlated with the
connection may in the if statement
that's wrong you know we can be you know
that's local if that's a local analysis
so we can do that fairly easily there
are other issues too with with
connections that will go into later but
you know eventually we want I mean we
want a system that's you know easy to
use that's that's sort of the primary
goal is to make it really easy to write
programs for people that maybe don't
even know see ya that you wouldn't fit
that that wouldn't work here would it
work well I mean I thought about this
before so else in the system is purely a
priority mechanism so there's no
disjunction negation going on you know
here there's mutually exclusive there's
already the the high branch the greater
than 90 and lesson for their already
mutually exclusive right there's no way
to really verify that so we don't you
don't try but the problem with the
disjunction model is just that you get a
lot of more connections and the
implementations sometimes you can't
maybe you can't take the negation of a
some more the more complicated the more
complicated conditions i'm going to show
later don't don't really support
negation so it's not maybe not feasible
but you know it's another way of
thinking about it and it works for
simple conditions surely
hardware system model no that's not the
goal of the project it's more about
building user interfaces ha yeah you
mean like sort of an interactive
programming yeah that's that's that's
definitely something I want to look at
but it's not something I'm not there yet
in the implementation probably not going
to be gonna be for my dissertation but
it's definitely it's definitely the way
of playing around is you want to add
conditions and maybe be tracked
conditions to you know interactively and
that's that's how you basically play
around and prototype a system sort of it
yeah so there yeah so I mean definitely
for email this is a little bit where the
email example I'm you is going to use in
this this this this top right you know
you have no coming in you have the user
you have multiple views user switching
through views I think you have that in
PowerPoint to you have you have the user
the user is also providing model data to
the system they don't call it models
right but if the user is also in putting
state into the system and that the
system is adjusting its views of of the
presentation based on the user input
that would be handled the same way well
c thick yeah so this is the NBC of the
NBC abstraction usually they distinguish
between input coming in from the data
model and input coming in from the user
and mice in the system you don't you
don't distinguish between that they're
both they're both state they're both
signals they're both sick signals coming
into the system but I mean this is this
sort of a simplification of the MVC
model I didn't really want to get into
it but um so there's a lot more
interaction going on inside your program
than just just interacting with your the
core data model that the user is
interested in there's also a lot of a
lot of other kind of interaction going
on between components you know based on
user interaction or just you know the
state of the operating system whatever
so there's there's a clip of
applicability you know is sort of a sort
of an issue too right you know you have
to have all these signals to make this
language worthwhile okay okay
it's true it's sure and this is this is
actually the approach that the
functional reactive programming people
take is what they do is they take
signals and they basically take your
your functional program and you
evaluated every time point that's sort
of the scheme implementation then
there's the Haskell implementations a
little more restrictive since signals
aren't first class values but you know
it's sort of that's that's the principle
that that that big out with so it's a
function program people have done
exactly that and I think starting in
1999 and this this I think this this is
a really interesting area of programming
language research it's not just me now
wait a second and I'll get to the
object-oriented part and that maybe
maybe become more clear why you would
you'd want sort of a circuit system as
opposed to a function system okay so
really quickly here this is basically
what the the interface for a driver
looks like that you would that you would
program to if you were writing Java code
to implement a signal or to use a signal
so outside in the super glue roll the
circuits are managed automatically by
the baby interpreter based on what
you've written in super glue code now
inside the job of world you know you
have to you have to like use signals
according to these sort of simple
interfaces but they're pretty manageable
all right so now I'm into objects the
problem with the signal connection model
and you know there's there are other
ways to handling this but I'm going to
do it with objects is that you know
there's a large number or unbounded
number of connections in a program and
you know this is because we have trees
or lists or really really complicated
structures and this means that you know
direct connections are not going to be
manageable so solution i'm going to
choose here is i'm going to basically
dispatch two connections like like like
you dispatch methods in an object rented
language we're going to use the type of
the signal container called an object to
figure out how its signal is is
connected right and then the other
option is you have a full programming
language like ml or scheme and you
evaluate the you have the full power of
that language to play around with you
don't have this issue you can start
abstracting over things like with
functions we're going to abstract over
things with objects and that's going to
be the primary difference okay so the
infamous class declaration so we're
going to have a we're gonna we're going
to declare our objects via classes and
in this language similar to java or c
sharp and we're going to have these
things called nested classes and they're
very these are very important in this
language because there's no way to
express an infinite number of
connections or an unbounded number or
large number of connections using top
level classes alone and the idea with an
asset class is that i have a tree tree
view widget so user interface tree and
it has a bunch of nodes inside it right
in each of each of those notes need to
be connected individually so i'm going
to do is I'm going to find a note class
and says okay whenever whenever the tree
view widget wants to figure out how I
know disconnected they'll just create a
node and say okay how is this node
connected so in the eye in the sense
we're going to have a way of creating an
unbounded number of signals in an object
using these nested classes and these
classes can be used as types or signals
so these are imported signals or signals
coming in to the object and we have a
root signal and that's that's a node and
we have each node signal has a list of
child node signals there are also nodes
okay so there there we go we have an
unbounded number of signals in this
object now right in costs and model data
is going to be this sort of a similar
way we have mailboxes with folders
folders have subfolders and the mailbox
has a root folder ok so we're describing
these sort of complex
sort of not complicated but large data
structures you know in in site using
classism okay so turn off with a program
connecting a treeview widget hold the
folder view to a mailbox object quote
mail and we're going to start off by
connecting the root of the folder or
we're going to start by connecting the
root folder of the mailbox to the root
of the folder view tree and then we have
to connect all the children of the fold
of the nodes in the folder view train we
could try to do this explicitly advice
expressing each connection individually
but of course that wouldn't work because
the trees and unbounded data structure
so what we're going to do instead is
we're going to abstract over all all
objects of type node in the way that you
would abstract over all objects using
this we're going to use these things
called dispatch variables to abstract /
tree notes okay so we have this VAR node
colin folder view node and with us
basically is doing is establishing a
dispatch variable that we can use to
talk about how no disconnect how nodes
are connected all nodes are connected
and we're going to combine that with if
the condition again to say that well you
know we have to have a way of reasoning
about how node is connected itself to
figure out how its how its signals are
going to be connected so if we say if
note is connected to a to an email
folder then we know we can connect its
children the children of the node to the
subfolders of the folder over the sorry
I always get my connection on because
I'm left right right left we can connect
the subfolders of the folders of a
folder to the children of the node okay
so now we've just expressed an entire
tree of connections of node connections
because this is this is this is going to
be applicable 40 notes now as a resolve
that connection I have more more nodes
connected to folders and then put more
folders connected to nodes and you know
and so on and I can also express other
connections inside here not just one
connection back an express an entire
group of connections that say how do I
deal with the fact how do I deal with
the situation where a where an email
folder is connected to a node you know
for note-for-note objects
okay so this is where we get into our
movie more advanced sort of illustration
so that the condition the condition
symbol is unchanged we have these these
dispatch variables and we're going to
model these sort of as boxes with you
know with addition of like multiple
boxes this connection statement which is
a condition it's basically this is where
I got into the fact that some conditions
might not be negated well actually this
this is probably negate able I don't
know the problem would be that folder
wouldn't be bound if you negated it we
have this connection symbol that says if
there's some folder connected to the
node variable so we have this is another
variable except unlike the node dispatch
variable which was you know universally
quantified over all nodes this folder
variable is sort of created and bound at
the same time via a condition statement
okay and that's going to capture the
folder that a note that a node is
connected to and now if it what oh yeah
okay sorry if this connection is true we
get an eval I didn't put this blue arrow
right here is basically it indicates
that the connection is true and we're
going to be able to connect um connect
subfolders to to the children up okay so
there's a little bit of rule driven
language going on here a little bit of I
don't know what you'd something like
unification but it's really just binding
is basically this this folder variable
this node variable is universe hort of
like universally quantified but really
only works for when you're connecting it
signals like like this and an object and
an object which is only University
quantified when you consider how its
methods are implemented and the folder
variable which is basically just
capturing whatever node is connected to
whatever is connected to node okay
so sorry hmm this is the type in the
syntax you have to specify what you are
what you're what you want want to query
that is what you want to query is
connect that note is connected to thank
you to yeah so if you want to say a
folder is connected to node right we
have to specify the type of that sort
sort of like a coercion you can think of
it as a coercion but it's really just
saying that ok no disconnected is can be
connected to something so what is it
connected to um let's see yeah you know
I'm reversing it again I always reverse
my connection syntax yeah only one thing
can be connected to node at a given time
no it can be connected to something else
I mean you can have you can have
connections they can they can run a line
and then they terminate somewhere so
like for example um hold it is connected
so uh so this is this is one thing
Boulder can only be connected to no no
that's not right sorry so folder is
being connected to node right but
nothing can be connected to folder
because folder is sort of has it has a
native object inside it and doesn't need
doesn't need to be connected doesn't
need to have anything connected to it so
something has so for something that's
about nested objects something has to be
connected to it for that nested object
to be meaningful and for other nested
objects like folder nothing needs to be
connected to it okay that's sort of the
way of thinking about it so
so what happens is that this rule
activates based on other connection so
the first the first connection made
between from the root folder to the root
node that creates a node that creates a
node that's that that the root folder is
connected to ok and then after this this
is this sort of connection is applied
this this lower connection is applied we
have more we have lists of folders being
connected to lists of notes and that
creates more more fodder for this rule
to execute now you know this isn't this
isn't going to lead to an infinite loop
or not necessarily depending on depends
on the components query the connections
on the mat so they say I want to know
what the connection of I want to know
how children is connected in some node
ok they're inside the component
implementations are going to ask for
these connections explicitly so that
this doesn't lead to a infinite loop or
you know sort of non termination unless
the component keeps asking for children
for no children you know recursively so
so it depends on the component
implementation whether this terminates
or not depends on what they do with the
data so like when you're building menus
they want to build those menus
aggressively so we'll ask for everything
for everything in the tree so your tree
better be a bounded height but if you're
building a building user interface
widgets they they assume that the tree
can have independent height so we're
only ask for things when we need it
their list yes think of it as connecting
a signal of type list to us another
signal of type list so there well
there'll be other signals that will be
automatically connected under there and
I'll get into that a little bit later ok
sure ok thanks all right let me go long
we're going to have prioritised dispatch
in this language too so this well we
have prioritize dispatch so the language
makes the language makes connections
based on the type of the object in a
prior and it prioritizes those
connections inside this inside the
circuit based on the type of the object
so just like you would prioritize a
virtual method dispatch in logical and
an object-oriented language ok so in
this example we have a mailbox a UI tree
in a table you I table we're going to
say ok when there's one node selected in
the folder view tree and that node is
and then there's a folder connected to
that note I'm going to connect the rows
of the message view table I'm going to
connect the messages of that folder to
the rows of the message view table
that's going to be one connection all
right
this is an operator weight equals equals
up here you mean okay this is this is
this is equality and this is connection
yeah yeah it was it was always always
been connection the previous slide now
the way i use equals here with these
angle brackets is different from what i
use it outside outside via statement
they're both dealing with connection but
they're dealing with yeah if is like a
let accept it can fail right i mean if
is like i mean if if this connection
might not be true right there could be
there could be many different kinds of
nodes inside the tree and so so yeah but
otherwise you could you know there's a
let there's a let thing that basically
is sugar for if that doesn't that that's
always true yeah yeah there is yeah
exactly you know it's it's like first
order logic to without the first sort of
logic so originally I i called this
unification then I got rid of the
unification Part to make the language
easier so hey it's great you know it's
wonderful to find language speaks tons
of interesting things programming
language research isn't dead that's what
I have to say despite what people say
okay and then we have a second
connection here which says for any table
this this dispatch variable again is
extracting overall all table objects and
saying okay the rows of those tables are
connected to an empty list and so this
this this bracket notation is is
declaring an empty list
ok now I have two connections to you
right tables here one is making a
specific connection to the message view
table and the other one is making a
general connection to any kind of table
and that's going to be significant and
how these two connections are
prioritized and these can be in
different source files by the way you
probably will be in different source
files ok so we get this huge gigantic
circuit here but basically what's going
on is that there's two there's two
connections to the tape to this message
view table 1 is the connection specified
to all tall table table view objects and
the other one is the specific connection
and when the size of the folder views
this when the notes selected in the
folder view are but you know when
there's only one node selected in the
folder view then and that that note is
also a folder then we can connect all
the way through to the we can connect
the messages of that folder to the to
the rows of the message we table and now
when when that's not true anymore we can
always connect an empty list to the to
the to the rosin if you if you if you
look at an email system you know when
you select a folder what happens you
know the messages appear when you do
select the folder what happens the
messages disappear you select two
folders it depends on the email client
but maybe the messages disappear again
and I'll show that recent I'll just show
that right now
this is I worked on this all night but I
didn't quite get it to work right so I'm
just show you some features here and
still but you know I didn't get the
progress i'm going to have to redo that
this i'm going to have to redo the
dispatch system but make it back so what
happens here is as i'm selecting the the
folders you know these things are the
different different lists are being
different different for different email
lists are being shown in the in the
table view in the message view now these
messages are totally bogus i just made
them up and randomize them but you know
you kind of get the idea now what
happens here is now if i select two
folders you know nothing happens but if
you look at the title is changing right
is changing it says okay what folder is
selected now you know how many folders
selected or no folder selected no title
and this expunge button is also changing
based on how many folders arts are
selected so if there's only one folder
selected I can expunge no folders to
folder selected I can explain to because
I don't know what folder i'm expecting
from and that's it now if we go to the
code it's not as pretty as the last code
it's sort of in disarray but you know we
have our abstraction over nodes in the
folder view to connect their to the
connector children we have our
abstraction over we have art we have our
connection to the rows of the message
view table that are saying okay if
there's only one row selected then i'm
going to show the messages of that of
that foot I mean if there's only one
folder select in the in the folder view
them is to show the messages of that
that folder and I'm also going to set
the title to the to the name of that to
name of that folder now if there's more
rows if what is this doing sorry it's
not not conclusive here if there's no if
there's no if there's no folder selected
I just say no folder selected in the in
the window of you and I don't say
anything else about how many how many
how many rows are displayed
and here i don't know why i wrote that
this isn't necessary actually i think
unless i have a bug but and if there's
if there's greater than one folder
selected in the folder view then I just
I just title the window and I don't
display any any messages in the UM and
the message view right and that's just
that's how this language work so you um
you abstract over your ear objects and
you connect them according to to the
data you have and notice that I've
combined dispatch of objects with this
with if else dispatch to those one of
the other sort of features of this
language is that you can write if blah
blah blah blah blah blah you can use
this type type way of dispatching these
connections and most time you have to do
both all right
so there's some other issues too like
there's some other features to get in so
we support class inheritance is this is
really interesting is just basically
saying we have objects sets of objects
that are related to each other we can
use that in prioritizing the connections
okay interfaces now this is getting sort
of to your question earlier somebody's
question really about lists is we have a
way of aggregating we have a way of
specifying of creating our higher level
abstractions using signals and we can
create label abstractions you can create
lists abstractions using using
interfaces and we can abstract /
interfaces likely with abstract /
objects okay so we have ways of creating
lists and we have ways we have a bit
ways of expressing list and we have ways
of expressing connections to lists and
if you connect to if you connect to
signals of the same list type and the
sub connections are made automatically
so that's why you could get away with
just saying list connected to list
because they're both lists types and so
we know how to connect their members
depends on where I'm putting the default
rule in the circuit so there's the
basically what happens is that when I
when I've implemented this I add a rule
I a data connection to the circuit that
sort of says okay you can connect it
this way if this if this condition is
true and now if if you can get a rule
above that and I think you can exciting
that rules really low priority then you
can change it but I don't know if you'd
want to I don't if you should I don't
know that should be allowed actually
abstraction for example i have here why
yeah you wouldn't want to encapsulate
that policy in a i don't think you would
want to encapsulate that policy in a no
connection you would want to encapsulate
that policy may be in a component is it
it's a lot more it's a lot more
complicated to implement that fat
connection so i think you would probably
have to implement as a component it's
not just that but I mean you would have
to you would have to interpose a
component on the on the connection
explicitly the component would have some
extra state to manage that but there's
filter components or sorting components
those kind of things a filter list but
you have to interpose them on the list
connection explicitly you can't just say
well if I connect these lists and
automatically sort them right and they
usually do require state especially the
way the signals work they have to be
interact they have to be online
constantly so if you have a sword
sorting lip of a sort of sorting
component it's actually going to have to
basically mirror the list so it can do
the sorting in tandem with the list so
yeah so component that's that's that's
the role that component serve all right
some more of the portable details
runtime errors so we've already talked
sort of like there's ways of else you
can have em big you can connect things
that are unrelated in else statements
which we can probably fix with type more
stronger type checking there are some
things that we can't fix very easily
with type checking which are ambiguous
connections you know what if you have
two two ways of connecting something and
there's no way to prioritize them you
know and if those are if those are if
statements then you know that's a
well-known impossible problem okay and I
don't have any easy answers for that
except debugging
sorry I have everything prioritized
prioritize that can be prioritized I
didn't give you an example of a
connection that couldn't be prioritized
so you could just say X you can say a
message you can take label color equals
red and labeled color equals blue on two
lines following each other it's valid
but it's it's ambiguous where is it
connected to router is connected to blue
you're not going to we don't use the the
ordering of the statements in the
program to resolve the resolve that so
yeah it's prioritized to the point to
the point where it can be and otherwise
it's not prioritizing you can have and
there's obvious there's there's a lot of
utility and having ambiguous connections
sorry
no no you want a prior you want to
prioritize things because you know what
the priorities are no you wouldn't like
for example in them in the first example
I gave you you didn't really need the
else statement that are between the B if
greater than 40 or if greater than 90
but you needed it for the default
connection which was on you know
connected to black and you needed that
else statement to sort of encompass both
of the if statement and that's why
that's why we had the else Clause is
there so it's it's you know there you
can definitely express Nvidia's
connections in this language and the
other one is you can also express you
can express subs situations where their
ardent there's no way to connect this
circuit there's no way to connect this
signal at the current time so maybe all
that all your rules are have conditions
on them and they're all not not true at
some time when you want to know what the
value of the signal is in that case you
know you get a sort of message not
understood error all right so the last
sort of feature in this language it's
not really related to objects but it
makes a language complete our streams
which basically allow you to interpose
on events and commands and it allows you
to do allows you to listen for events
and allows you to dispatch commands and
allows you to iterate over data so if
you look at the signal model at Heights
control flow completely from from the
programmer and that's great it hides a
lot of complexity from the programmer
but you know it's not sustainable
there's lots of there's lots of cases
where you actually need to start looking
at control flow and you actually need to
expose a little bit of control flow to
the programmer so one thing is you know
we have buttons the push behavior of a
button is obviously discrete you cannot
model that as a signal so you model as
an event instead so we have this on on
statement which is a nut which is like
if but it's for event we can iterate
over a raise of data using them do
syntax so we have a list of selected
rows and we have this all all array
signal that basically returns all the
elements of the of the of the selected
of them sorry of the message you table
and so so so basically what we're doing
in here is a great basically dispatch
specifying a for loop that iterates over
all of the all of all the messages in
this table and we can perform command so
we can perform a command that deletes
the message so when the button is pushed
iterate over all the selected messages
in the message we table and delete them
that's what this code is expressing and
to to know these these abstractions the
stream abstractions are compatible with
signals but if you're only using stream
abstractions in your program there's no
benefit to using super glue you have to
be using signals to actually get a
noticeable benefit in this language the
stream abstractions are just there so
you don't have to switch to Java all the
time to to to reason about control flow
because you can't mean this is actually
the array of data is a signal it's just
an array of signals and you can't you
can't do anything with that though you
can't connect under you can connect
array of signal array of signals but you
can't test an array of signals as in a
condition yeah at least in the language
you can use components to do that for
you if you want but the problem with the
Ray data is that you can't you know
there's no aggregate operators in this
language and it's not clear what those
aggregate operators would look like so
instead we have separate abstractions
you know if you're dealing with a list
you say this list is equal to this list
the all signal is still there but you
never use it you know it's used by the
receivers of the lists it's hot is
hidden from you you don't have to use it
if you don't want to right and that's
how we get the signal behavior we take
things we take a raise of data we
package them up in higher level
abstractions like lists and we exchanged
those between components now what if the
components disagree on list abstractions
now we hope that they're using the same
list but they're not using the same list
you have to implement an adapter then
you have to touch these um these these
arrays signal wait array signal
abstractions to do that translation you
see what I'm saying kind of
i wish to i would i would totally have i
mean this is this is this is my plan in
the beginning was to say everything's
going to be a signal right that was my
plan and it didn't work or everything is
not a signal the problem is you have a
lot of behavior in programs that is not
representable as a signal and then
expressing that behavior in this
language was impossible to do we have to
we have to write all these components to
express this behavior which is just
ridiculous and and actually there's a
little bit of snot I'm gonna call
synergy but the compatibility with
signals means that i can actually
express these on statements and do
statements in the context of an if
statement which allows me to get the
benefits of signals with an command not
not not lose them when i have to use
streams you know eventually you know
this maybe i'll talk about it talk about
now is eventually you want to come up
with these high-level components that
only have signal abstractions you know
you don't want to be dueling for example
with buttons because buttons you know
they can be pushed you want to be
dealing with forms the forms can have
signal like behavior where all the low
level event handling details are are
hidden from you but if you're dealing
with it just an individual button you
have to deal with the fact that the
button can be pushed right so the idea
is now you have to you focus on the
component you know higher level
components to get more signals and then
you can hide these details I'm almost
done this is like I have I have three
slides left so first we have sort of an
evaluation and this was done by hand so
we constructed a sort of a small email
client in our email viewer in Java and
we constructed an email viewer in super
glue the email viewer in super glue
doesn't exactly work yet but you know
the lit parses and you know when the
implementation is done it will work but
we wanted to compare the implementations
to figure out what the benefit of using
this language would be like so what we
did was we can we compared the line
count and we found that you know the
superglue program is like sixty percent
smaller when you compare lines of code
now this this is a little bit lines of
code or a little bit bogus because you
know you can take pearl and
everything is you can express everything
in one line in Pearl right but it's not
going to be useful so we looked at
another metric here or basically
counting operations we took method calls
we took signal connections we took casts
we took instantiations something that
seems significant that would have
complexity to the programmer we didn't
we didn't weigh those complexities we
just assume that all the complexities
were the same for the for the basis of
this evaluation and it turns out that at
least for this exam fewer superglue is
only thirty five percent better than
Java which is which is which is a
significant benefit but you know it's
not you know we were hoping that would
be ninety percent but maybe maybe later
when we understand the language more and
we use higher level components we can
get a better benefit and the drivers of
course you if you want to include that
complexity there's a lot there a lot of
code but that's reusable between between
different programs we go backwards so
basically what happened here is that
most of signal connections are simple
and they're not using the if statements
to compose the signal connections there
are obvious examples where you can use
if statements to compose signal
connections but then there are a lot
most of the code in the program is just
saying okay connect this to those
connected to this connective is this
there are a few compositions and these
compositions lead to really you know the
order of magnitude type of reduction of
code but the problem is they're just not
enough of them we would get more
benefits with higher level widgets as I
specify before if we can get more
signals into the system then we can get
more benefit and the other kind of point
here is that I'm shifting to the
conclusion is that right now we've only
looked at building user interfaces and I
think there's a lot of interesting work
out there I mean interesting domains
that can benefit from a language like
this for example ubiquitous computing
where you have a lot of volatile date
data to deal with and you have a lot of
integration custom integration to do
sort of small integration tasks to get
that data to work together okay
this is a general purpose language
general-purpose programming language so
you would only write glue code in this
language and you would only right glue
code for a specific domain of programs
like user interface programs or not
general purpose not general not like
Java right not like mm-hmm we actually
do have loops we have iteration which is
like looping but it's not it's well okay
when I say it's not general I'm not
saying it's not turing-complete I'm just
saying it's not meant to be general a
big difference but so we can't do non
interactive programming and actually
actually if you want to look at the task
of getting arbitrary programs to work in
super glue it's sort of like getting
paralyzing their components to work in
sort of interactive ways which is a
well-known hard problem but you know
it's an interesting it's an interesting
problem maybe maybe that's the way we
can make programming easier is to try to
figure out how we can make our
components more interactive okay
implementation we have an interpreter
written in Java we get to reuse java's
garbage collector which is great we have
to write our own it's not tuned it's not
that fast but it's fast enough for you
is future work we're going to look at
compiling circuits and eliminating
unused connections because you have a
lot of connections there especially the
object orientation to I don't even apply
to your search apply to your object but
can't be pruned out because we don't
know they don't apply and an inlining
connection dispatch into Java code
directly or some other language like C++
to make it faster and some little bit of
related work here so I mentioned the
functional reactive programming stuff at
the beginning of the talk there's yappin
fruit which are high school systems or
synchronous and I think they have
problems with connection scaling those
they've addressed this in a couple
dissertations already but the solutions
are really at hot there's another system
called father time at brown by greg
cooper and its systems about a lot more
scalable it's asynchronous like
my system is it's basically the
differences between these two systems
are i'm using a connective sort of
object-oriented abstraction to as
opposed to the functional programming
now whether which one is easier to use i
think is an interesting question yes the
first one has a notion is actually the
first one is basically a rise out of
sort of hardware hardware systems
they're actually synchronous languages
before these functional very functional
reactive programming systems in the
ninth in the late 80s Early 90s that
actually had some notion of continuous
evaluation and these systems sort of
evolved that into sort of more
general-purpose programming constructs
okay and that's it so questions or
Oh
I don't um well I don't have well I
don't have specific reasons about my
system yet because the implementation is
still buggy and therefore i'm debugging
the implementation as i'm debugging
these programs now when it does work
it's just really easy it seems to me
like it's really easy so this is sort of
my my opinion that really to really find
out if it's easy you really have to go
to third parties you have to do a lot of
testing user testing and it's not ready
it's not ready for that yet now there is
research at CMU pain jhansi pain he did
the Hat the hands programming language
if you're familiar with that he
basically basically went it's a
programming language for children he
went to them and the assam a lot of e
did a survey of initial survey before
the language began as some will have a
question so found out that people you
know people like to reason about
programs in terms of events or
continuous behavior as opposed to
sequential control flow which is kind of
obvious when you think about it but you
know coming from the stem the viewpoint
of programmers used to programming in
c++ we kind of forget that and he
actually went through and tested the
language you know the effects and stuff
like that and i don't owe some of that
research is sort of transferable the
super glue but we would have to do a
study along those lines to with with you
know probably adult adults rather than
children
well you don't do this the things you're
not connecting wires down you're
applying functions you can't I mean I
mean that people are you you can you can
think of a function application at in
terms of circuits but it's really not
you have recursion you have a lot of
really powerful things going on there
and it's not you know you can say that
well I can be sure that this is going to
happen because i have a function
application but you don't really know
what's happening inside the function
application and you know or you have to
write a complicated function application
to do to do what you want i mean i think
that's that's that's sort of the
potential differences between my system
in their system now that that would have
to be borne out in you know whether
connecting things with objects is easier
than function application we would have
to do a lot of you know it's either it's
either a it's either a philosophy your
philosophical issue with no answer or
its requires a lot of user testing Oh
will the typeface dispatch the type
specific IP the type based dispatch is
sort of easier than then the base
dispatch so type a suspect you can you
can specify default connections and you
specified at those in signatures that
are public notnot implementations that
are private so the user has access to
all the default connections to reason
about and they don't without reasoning
about the implementations of the
components themselves now the other
thing is like if you export a signal
from a component then you have to
connect it if in the cosine abstract and
you have to connect it that's that's
simple I'm not simple but it's like sort
of I don't know it's like you you have
you can you can reason about how imports
are connected but for the experts are
connect are completely encapsulated from
the from the user so you at you as a
component implementer have to either
write really good documentation or make
sure that the signals already always
connected with some kind of default
behavior
this is my this is my this is my this is
my dissertation and I'm I'm not this
actually grew out of my previous work
which is kind of hard to see the
resemblance now there was a lot of
soul-searching right we had before i had
an aspect-oriented programming language
you know using logic programming core
and the problem with that is not very
effective at making programming easier
so I tried I kept in extending the
abstraction and eventually I found okay
this model works really well and I can
get rid of all this other stuff because
they don't add anything and that's what
we came up with so yeah it's it's it's a
bit you know I have I have a lot of
projects that i'm not writing my
dissertation on so sort of well you know
Dawson keeps saying I should just staple
papers together and get out but I really
wanted to do something I really wanted
to do something this is sort of my
chance to do to look at this issue and
you know once you're an industry you
gotta be more pragmatic I think I I done
i think that that's just as philosophy
on them grad school but yeah I you know
Wilson wants me to staple things
together to and get out but everybody
wants me to get out was for that way
none this is not necessarily not
necessarily you could actually like look
like ubiquitous computing right it's not
very well supported yet with a lot of
existing applications or existing
abstractions you could actually position
your language into an edge and you know
this there's a lot of nichy languages
out there and that can that can also be
a way of instead of convincing people to
change what they're doing now just say
oh look you can do new things with this
language and I think that's better too
you don't want to convince you don't
want to say this is a better c or c++
wants a look I have these components and
I have this language and look what the
look what you can do with these
components in this language and if
people want start wearing their own only
own components that's great but you
don't have to like you don't have to
take the approach of saying well we're
going to we're going to redo the way you
program you just you know this like this
like like you still market share from
your competitors or you create new
market share yeah and I think you can do
it the other way so big annulment I
guess a lunch crew